على بعد عده اشهر من الانتخابات في تركيا
تستمر استراتيجيه الرئيس التركي بتامين
الحدود التركيه واضعاف الاحزاب الكرديه
وميشياتها العسكريه المتميزه جنوب البلاد
العمليات العسكريه وصلت الى مرحلتها
السادسه منذ ان بدات عام 2015 اي مع
التقدم الكردي شمال سوريا بدعم من
الولايات المتحده ودول التحالف الدولي ضد
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه الرئيس التركي قال
مؤكدا ان الغارات الجويه التي بدات الاحد
الماضي هدفها اقامه حزام امنيا ورده على
التهديدات الكرديه داخل البلاد اخرها
التفجير في اسطنبول
الملايين من النساء والاطفال
ان شاء الله على طول حدودنا من الغرب الى
الشرق الحزام الامني يشمل العلاقه ايضا
حيث تضرب تركيا وايران في شمال العراق
مواقع لحزب الحريه الكردستاني ويشمل
اعتقالات ومداهمات داخل تركيا الغارات
والقذف المدفعي القادم من القواعد التركيه
بريف حلب الشمالي تستهدف كوباني او عين
عرب حيث تسيطر قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وزير الدفاع التركي خلص اكار ذكر سفيري
الولايات المتحده وروسيا باتفاقهما عام
2019 الذي يقضي بانسحاب وحداته حمايه
الشعب الكردي على بعد 30 كلم عن الحدود
بعد دعوات بلديهما انقر الى ضبط النفس
وبعد ان قالت واشنطن ان الضربات التركيه
تهدد امن جنودها 900 الباقين شمال سوريا
القوات الكرديه طلبت الدعم من اصدقائها
حسب بيان وقالت ان المقاتلات التركيه تقصف
مواضيعها
يحتجاز فيها عناصر لتنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه فيما تظاهر القرد في كوباني